لا يهدا السنجال بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا التي تؤكد انها ستحاول العثور على
حطام الطائره المسيره الامريكيه بعدما
اتهمت واشنطن موسكو بالتسبب في سقوطها
بالبحر الاسود قباله اوكرانيا
لا اعلم ما اذا كنا سنستطيع انتشار
المسيره لكن يجب القيام بذلك وسنعمل في
هذا الاتجاه بالتاكيد يعد الحادث دليلا
اخر على ان الولايات المتحده طرف المباشر
في المعركه بين موسكو تتحمل روسيا مسؤوليه
الدفاع عن استقلالها وسيادتها
تؤكد المخابرات الروسيه ان لدى موسكو
والامكانيات التقنيه لانتشال حطام المسيره
الامريكيه فيما اكد المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون كيربي
ان انتشار المسيره معقد للغايه لم يتم
انتشار المسيره ولست متاكدا من اننا
سنتمكن من ذلك سقطت في مياه عميقه للغايه
في البحر الاسود ولذا ما زلنا نقيم ما اذا
كنا سنقوم باي نوع من جهود الانتشال ام لا
يؤكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي انه ابلغ نظيره
الروسي سرق شويغو بان واشنطن ستواصل تحليق
طائراتها في المجال الجويه
قمت لتوب باغلاق الهاتف مع نظير الروسيه
الوزير شويكو كما قلت مرارا من المهم ان
تكون القوه العظمى نماذج للشفافيه
والتواصل وستواصل الولايات المتحده
الطيران والعمل اينما كان القانون الدولي
يسمح بذلك ويتعين على روسيا تشغيل
طائراتها العسكريه بطريقه امنه ومهنيه
روايتان مختلفتان لسقوط المسيره الامريكيه
واشنطن تتحدث عن تهور روسي وموسكو تصف
الحادث بالاستفزاز الامريكيه